let's rate hot to sure that the monthly
repayment is approximately and then they
keep you at all feel okay we do this
program in from a minute this is a
really important point before I show you
how this is done and then turn this into
just like a recipe think about all of
the knowledge you have about this
situation and how you would arrive at
that number how you would solve and
that's what you're trying to do any
wanna throw an idea
traditional okay so I think oh you
should make something equal zero but my
question to all of you teach you to hold
fire this is per second my question to
all of you is what am I going to let
equal zero for instance not a rhetorical
question and I gotta let this equal zero
yes reason none because this is only
after two months unless you have really
deep pockets you are not paying this all
up for two months and so the re is not
because that one is playing right so
according to our ease plan what is he
going to let zero let B equal to zero a
300 a 300 by definition is the amount
going after that 300 payment and that's
when one of you finish need all of this
right so I can say pot to a 300 that
should equal zero
right I mean this line is really
important doesn't seem to say very much
but it communicates to me that you know
when you're talking about in terms of
each other
it's a piece of this question so what is
it remember how I guess it is
well I don't really want to play
something with 301 turns in it so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to as we did
in the superannuation question I'm going
to generalize right I am going to find
after how many months is in part three
right would you not going am I'm just
going to go for a general a and now in
order to get there think about normal
student sequences how many terms do you
need to like establish at home three
right because if I gave you say one
comma two any two terms you don't know
if this is an AP or a GP so the next
number could be great or it could be
fall right so I need a third term before
I can get to the general term so let's
do that together
everything here remember two things
happen every single time right
everything she gets interesting I do it
like this right and it is a remainder so
everything that's there I'm going to
rewrite with an extra lot of interest so
in 360 the 360 thousand it's now got
three lots of interest ative implied two
extra one this repair has to this
repayment has one and then here's the
mysterious one okay so far so good now
at this point here I'd like to make it
clearer what kind of pattern I'm going
to fall okay so I think it at this point
I could say look at these guys here
right look at them
I've got one two three terms because
there have been three repayments so in
my alerts you make the nth term is going
to be how many of these repentance there
we end of them and how many times is
interest being applied to this no
regional down n times you can look at
the numbers and you can match it all up
so this would be and unfortunate our
whiteboard is not quite bigger so I'm
going to write this next field
slide take away this very first
repayment and how many lots of interest
have been applied to it yeah one this
you see that use this is one of the
reasons why we established that happy
rather say something use it using some
formula right in the beginning it's so
that we can see that is right so n minus
one the next one will be one less than
that etc I still the moistness and then
we finished with the very lost that's
300 or rather the N 3 minute
yes okay okay now this guy here this
theme and I've written with all these
terms over here this is a GP right so in
order to show that I recognize that it
is such and I can replace it with a
point of I'm gonna say this peak young
is a dream eight okay
[Music]
what is asked repayment and have
interest apply what do you guys regular
how can I wake up with the answer is yes
it will be a one point there is your
life on there or whether they work what
information could I use it because
that's a really good question because
sometimes depending on the situation it
will use your supply and sometimes I'm
going to have you in this case what
clues do I have introduced that written
down tell me anything with your missile
not really
yeah I did so I'm sure the boss came in
yeah yeah so like when you pick up game
and you fully pay off your debt so there
won't be any more interest after that
was paid at all okay let me just repeat
see if I understand you correctly
Russell this last repayment it should
completely wipe out the loan it should
be robot it's finished now right so if
that is the case then interest only gets
applied when a new month starts off
right well there won't be a new month
after this one because this is the final
repayment yeah that's true that's
completely valid there's another thing
that you could accomplish is the reason
why I've written down so much working so
far which is how did my terms usually
how did my equations rather usually end
well there's a minus M over here on the
third one there's a minus M over here on
the second one and there's a minus M
over here on the first one and it has no
interest applied to it so where's the
last thing that happens so does that
make sense does that show you why it's
just amazing okay so now I can
generalize this by saying it's a GP move
what features what's the first term and
you can say this in a couple of
different ways you can say this guy is
the first term and then climb off the
palace or you can say this guy is the
first term because that's the way I've
written it and then climb down the house
which would you prefer which you think
is easier sorry
that's a related question yesterday the
second yeah okay so let me come to the
that's off and their question is asked
later on what is this not included in
the series why am i sort of exercising
from the GTA and what makes GP
what's the definition of the junior
yeah it's a collaboration between each
tone okay now to get from here to here
is there a common ratio I can multiply
baguettes in from here to here that's
the same there's one I hear from you
yeah and here and here all the other
ones the answer is because of this need
360 thousand which is because of this
bigger more to do with this video the
answer is no right
like whatever I multiply to get from
here is going to be a different number
so it's staying out the front it's not
in the GP so it's a bit of a round it in
the liner over there okay all these
other terms with all of the monthly
repayments attached they're viewing the
bits in the geometric progression does
that make sense
now just going back to this one
right i administered yes we start with
this timing it's just easier to write an
hour in the system to go quite the
opposite
so my first term a is going to be equal
to
yeah it's a mindset right what's the
ratio how do I go from one term to the
next to the next most likely turist
right that's going to be a common
feature that's your shape how many times
of it this is the the end one so there
are any limits so they're up in that
okay all right so now I can actually
replace all of that with like something
to paint this 360 thousand of Mario's 20
off the board is still probably hanging
out the [ __ ] there okay and now we're
going to put it in what is the sum of
achievement do you bet one do you have
the formula there is in your mind yet
you've been doing
okay so I want top of the fraction up on
top of the fraction is hey okay what am
I gonna have here and I wanna wish for
should I use
yeah I think I should be sorry - one key
on cuz that will make the denominator R
minus 1 which would be positive okay so
here's my to the N minus 1 and then on
the denominator he's my boy hey happy
where you tighten something good right
that's it
that's how the kids praise 60,000
there's a minus sign from the first step
what wins here is verified to the N you
can't really do very much with that but
what you have a look at this guy down
the water hmm 0.005 and so the
denominator 0 plus your survives a
fraction right so actually dividing by a
fraction
oh my - winter that's just simply to do
it so how do I do that
how do I calculate all right you told me
what something divided one divided by
zero point zero zero bodies that would
also work but I don't have a yeah I
can't I can multiply which is you mended
right did you yeah okay
what was the point of me doing that I
look back to the very first line that I
wrote in this project
yeah I want to sit a and another two
three hundred and then I'm gonna
actually get to zero okay so I'm going
to yeah
it's like let's set em to me 300 so
that's three hundred and sixty thousand
one point zero zero five tada 300 right
that's what it best apiece take away
okay let's see ya take a better rapport
see it for two reasons number one I'm at
the end of my boy number two even though
this looks kinda in person Missy
even though it looks kind of gross and
messy you just really need to change the
subject that's all this is this is
another what your calculator you can do
it this is remember that you have to do
it this is just a rearrangement involved
they even told me what the answer ought
to be so I'm going to give you a second
to rearrange it does say show so you
can't just say oh equals this I still
have a bit of actually rearranging it
out of eight what to do